so how's it different if you're doing
MMA well there's a lot of difference
because and uh
in grafting you set up for example you
take down from him fighting
in MMA
there's different styles
I like to be using
proactive and reactively down
very often I use one of my longest
weapon as a decoy to get in your leg
lose my job
to create a distraction
then
I can get in
um
other guys for example
like Habib are more like
chain rest or they shoot sometime but
they're very good at using for example
that the advances
like
pushing you to the fast and then from
there
they're using their
the resting from there so I'm more of a
more of a dynamic of yeah I like to
explode so that's one of my strengths
which khabib is very good for example at
uh
very good technically and is very strong
in isometric strength I I heard so he's
very good with this style of wrestling
do you think you can take uh the bead
down I think I think I could yeah I
think he could take me down as well but
so how do I design against this
so so there's there's many ways
um first you need to be aware of the
distance control that's one of the
things I was the best at
to master the distance control you need
to master the footboard to be always in
balance and ready to explode a lot of
guys I don't know how to manage distance
control also because they're not that
good footwork they cross their leg they
go all over the place so when you move
it's important when if I go left or push
off with my right
I go back I push with my lead
I go forward I push with my back this is
the basic thereafter
you can use different illusion so if I'm
here I look like I'm more of a threat to
you that if I'm here but I mean I'm at
the same distance
so one of my favorite which setup I take
down a single or double I use my jab
which is one of my longest weapon of
course my legs are longer but I like the
jab to create the distraction so if I'm
here you see me coming so I use a
distraction I'm here and like I call bro
like a snake will launch itself and it's
free I'm using my body to Boom so you're
you have a false spelling of security
now because you think I can't touch you
but because of my leg
and my job start outside of your field
of vision so I'm not doing this
I'm doing purposing and putting it down
and I'm here and I'm attracting your
attention here because I'm moving my
hand
boom once I tag you once or twice
now I have a perfect setup because
you're not in fighting you have a
short-term memory
you you always remember what hurts you
the last and it's my job then I can very
I plant a seed in your mind and I can go
up and getting easier when you finish
how you drop there's many ways the best
highest per second move is the elbow
deep double leg so when I get him
I try to look across when I step across
so again then I go elbow deep the reason
why I don't only go with my legs is
because if I if you're stronger and
bigger than me and you sprawl from there
I can have a hard time but if I go elbow
deep
because of the leverage you can't Sprout
once I'm in I look across and I drive
across
be down sometimes you'll fight a guy
like for example Bisping was very strong
and I couldn't drive across
so when that happened
if you can't drive across you turn the
corner
guys that's they get they open up on the
other side would you like to try sure
yeah
so from here
yes go with your
elbow deep here
and now you're gonna drive across
yes step across with you yes
if you do it again
good job
hot
yes yes exactly and if I give you
resistance
once you get in I'm strong at you and
I'm I'm spraying my leg if you turn the
corner so yeah I've set it up a few
times yeah
I'm sprawling yes
very nice you feel you feel the
difference yeah so if if it's too strong
you go on the other side don't force for
that don't waste your energy for another
you try to be as economic as you can